hello again I want to talk about why apple cider
vinegar works for weight loss okay it really has
nothing to do with nutrition in the apple cidervinegar it has to do with the acetic acid
okay acetic acid lowers the output of insulin it
improves insulin resistance that's amazing and it
also decreases blood sugars and improves the a1c
which is the average blood sugars for about three
months so since insulin is the main hormone that
causes you to gain weight anything that improves
insulin will help you lose weight I'll put some
links down below to give you more information on
the research behind it but very simple you take a
tablespoon of apple cider vinegar okay does it have
to be Bragg's no it can pretty much be any vinegar
I mean I like the organic better because of you
know no pesticides but just do one tablespoon is
all sort of integrate in a glass of water I do a
little more than 8 ounces I'll probably do 12
ounces one tablespoon of lemon okay lemon also
helps blood sugars by the way now some people
put honey Tupelo Honey or raw honey I do that
unless it's for your kids or you're not trying to
lose weight because there is that sugar there but
some people like to offset the taste but instead
just to stevia liquid stevia lemon drops or just
liquid stevia and that will sweeten in a little
bit and that'll just make it a nice little lemon
drink okay next question is like when to take
it I like to do one in the morning one in the
evening some people do it with their meals
if they have a digestive issue it's not a bad
idea and you can even add one one with a meal
just to improve your digestion or some people
even take one in the morning and one in the
evening an empty stomach it's not a problem
you can even take it before bed all right so go
ahead and apply this and put your comments below